michel david à montréal vincent marissal
à montréal et sébastien pauvert à québec
bonsoir messieurs trois soirs si vous le
voulez bien on va écouter à deux
extraits important aujourd'hui
ghislain picard et monsieur couillard ce
matin on écoute le premier responsable
de cette crise ici à val d'or c'est le
premier ministre du québec
donc on demande que le premier ministre
monsieur couillard se manifeste dans les
meilleurs délais possibles dans les 24
heures 24 prochaines heures
notre intention est de le sommer à une
rencontre avec l'ensemble des premières
nations au niveau du québec labrador
l'enjeu de fond là c'est cette loi
désuète 255 et la loi sur les indiens
qui malheureusement la garde nos peuples
autochtones dans un état de dépendance
qui me paraît contraire à leur terre on
a les deux éléments importants le court
terme
l'enquète la demande de rencontre avec
le premier ministre et le fond du
problème qui perdure depuis des
décennies au canada cette relation avec
les autochtones les autochtones qui avec
raison se lève la main en disant nos
communautés vivent 150 ans derrière vous
bon prenons la première partie monsieur
michel david
là le gouvernement se fait attaquer tout
par la mine et son lui demande de
démissionner on a mis au jour d'hui in
extremis aux observateurs aux policiers
de montréal qui vont débarquer à val
d'or qu'est ce que vous en dites
comprennent pas finalement demandé à ce
bureau des enquêtes de se mettre sur
pied un plus vite
ben c'est ce serait la solution la plus
la plus évidente est sinon tout le
bureau au moins celle qui est en charge
du bureau qui pourrait former un comité
ad-hoc comme on dit pour se saisir de la
question
parce que là un simple observateur sa
volée c'est malgré tout une ça va
demeurer une enquête policière des soit
à montréal ou à la sûreté du québec ce
sont des policiers qui vont enquêter sur
des policiers à sa face même c'est pas
crédible maintenant
monsieur khouya ne semble pas vouloir
aller plus loin que ça je pense pas
qu'il se laisse non plus convoqué comme
ça par l'assemblée des premières nations
il va certainement donner signe de vie
mais on l'entend quand tu parles de la
loi sur les indiens c'est qu'il veut
manifestement établir la discussion sur
une base beaucoup plus large que la
simple crise là à val d'or parce que
vincent donc parallèlement touchant le
dit depuis plusieurs jours il ya le
gouvernement fédéral qui va lancer sa
commission
une promesse de justin trudeau mais à
court terme la a ils doivent rétablir
rapidement la confiance avec les
citoyens
oui parce que la promesse de justin
trudeau oui c'est une pole man in quand
une enquête nationale comme son enquête
nationale mais ça touche le moins qu'on
déroge ça touche la disparition et le
meurtre d'un peu près 1200 femmes
autochtones depuis une vingtaine
d'années le problème est qu'une
commission denquête on l'a vu encore
avec charbonneau le la dernière en date
c2c de circonscrire le mandat d'une
telle commission
qu'est ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on fait
un immense fourre tout parce que les
problèmes de relations entre les blancs
les autochtones et les problèmes dans
les communautés autochtones sont
tellement race patrice peut faire une
commission denquête permanent pendant
rien tant qu'on n'aura même pas fait le
tour de la question encore alors ce qui
se passe à val-d'or je pense c'est une
question de d'affaires criminelles ou
potentiellement criminel c'est donc une
histoire d' enquête sur des jambes et
des policiers qui ont peut-être faute et
ce sont des allégations
ils ont droit à la présomption
d'innocence mais la première chose qu'on
doit faire le danser faire la lumière
sur ce qui s'est passé ou non
je pense que le monsieur couillard
d'accord avec michel couillard crois pas
qu'il va répondre à cette demande d'aidé
autochtone c'est pas son genre il est
généralement beaucoup beaucoup de place
à ses ministres il est en retrait mais
ce quia contrairement à d'autres
premiers ministres qu'on a connu mais là
quand il évoque la vétusté de la loi
fédérale
je pense qu'il faut un grand grand grand
détour pour pas parler du vrai problème
le vrai problème en ce moment val
d'allos un problème possiblement d'abus
policiers sur des communautés
autochtones et et ami michel david on
est ce que le gouvernement ne devrait
pas profiter de cette crise là pour
justement ouvrir la machine puis envoyé
comme vous
un comité un ex-juge mais vraiment
quelque chose qui pourrait par la nature
de l' annonce apaiser tout le monde sait
jamais la bonne
le temps idéal dans position de crise
pour établir une structure un peu large
mais il va falloir que monsieur
couillard trouve une solution une
réponse parce que on peut pas imaginer
là que les chefs des premières nations
vont camper à val-d'or en attendant
qu'il se passe quelque chose et là on
nous dit qu'il ya d'autres michelin
picard le s'entendent aujourd'hui qu'à
d'autres révélations qui pourraient
s'ajouter au cours des prochains jours
il va y avoir un espèce de build up qui
va se faire il éclate mais ce quillard
devra dire plus que ce qu'il ne dit
jusqu'à présent j'avais juste lundi car
en entrevue tout de suite après sa
conférence de presse
on n'aime pas quand on pose la question
la responsabilité aussi des leaders
autochtones non pas dans les abus
policiers évidemment mais dans ce climat
dans la violence qui peuvent être faites
aux femmes dans leur communauté
là on est allergique à salah vous avez
vous êtes peut-être pas entendu
l'entrevue mais qu'est-ce que vous il ya
une responsabilité aussi autochtone dans
tout son michel bien entendu une
responsabilité autochtone mais je
comprends que les premières nations vont
se sont beaucoup plus enclines à lancer
de blâme sur le gouvernement mais
écoutez les abus dans les réserves sont
pas simplement le fait des policiers
dans ce que c'est on sait que oui il ya
des allégations très sérieuse mais des
phénomènes de femmes battues de d'abus
de boissor à écouter des histoires qu'on
attend depuis des décennies alors le
problème est sérieux avec la police mais
un problème de criminalité le dans ce
cas ci mais c'est beaucoup plus vaste
bien entendu vincent justement puis vous
le disiez la commission que mettra sur
pied justin trudeau risque d'être très
large et tout ça là il ya une crise qui
émerge à val d'or
est ce que il pourrait pas avoir une
réponse entre guillemets québécoise à
tout ça avec une plus petite commission
plus agile avec comme mission des
solutions concrètes qui peuvent être
transposées ailleurs aussi je crois pas
patrice qu'on devrait créer une
commission spécifiquement à cause de ce
qui se passe à val d'or en ce moment je
pense que ce qui se passe à val-d'or jeu
je le redis c'est cédant cadre d'une
enquête sur des actes potentiellement
criminel on doit aussi rétablir la
confiance du public envers des excuses
mais surtout des communautés autochtones
envers là est ce qu je pense qu'on doit
d'abord faire la lumière sur ce qui
s'est passé après plus qu'on s'embête en
entrée ou vouloir entrer dans une
période de collaboration entre le
fédéral et les provinces
québec peut très très bien c'est inclure
dans une grande enquête nationale sur le
sort des autochtones sort pitoyable
faut-il le dire parce que oui michel par
les toxicomanies de violences conjugales
et des enfants de 11 ans dans les
communautés autochtones qui se suicident
parce qu'ils n'ont pas d'autres
solutions à 11 ans imaginez c'est un
drame en devenir depuis des années et
lorsqu'on fait en ce moment c'est ce que
les anglais appellent pardonner le terme
anglophone un blème game qu'on pourrait
traduire c'est le jeu du blanc tout le
monde se renvoie le blâme l'opposition
blâme la ministre thériault lui demande
sa démission
le tout à l'heure ce n'est qu'en dit la
première le produit responsable c'est
monsieur couillard pas sûr que l'on peut
faire faire porter le drame le sur les
épaules du premier ministre hier tous
renvoyé les blancs comme cela on fait
pour en fait pas la lumière le blâme que
moi je fais au gouvernement c'est de
faire encore une fois qui a été la
police sur la police dans une communauté
traumatisée par la police bon et le
bureau d'enquêté on le disait au tout
début un michel
le gouvernement rétorque qu'il n'est pas
prêt qu'il sera prêt au printemps et
l'opposition divers et peut-être plus
mais c'est pas le bureau dans laquelle
ça peut être quelqu'un d'autre on peut
nommer un juge le moment que ce soit un
comité où une commission indépendante le
mot clé là dedans c'est indépendant de
la police l'ayant l'observateur qui est
envoyé en vain requis ce qui serait
utile que fera t-il quel sera son mandat
je veux à vendre pour ceux qui se
demandent la sébastien beauvais on l'a
pas éjectés on a des problèmes de sons
avec québec j'avais demandé d'être là on
s'excuse sébastien on veut on se
reprendra demain je veux conclure il
nous reste un peu plus d'une minute
précieux il ya 20 états le loving à
montréal on voit les documentaires on
repart bien sûr de ce référendum c'est
l'anniversaire vingt ans plus tard à
michel david réflexion sur le loving
et vincent suite on voit les images la
voile à wimereux la veine tous ceux qui
avaient participé avait été un peu comme
on dit mal à l'aise de cette éruption
très tardive du canada anglais qui
étaient venus nous nous dire combien il
nous aimait et surtout le peu de suites
que ça a eu parce que finalement cet
amour-là s'est pas concrétisé
au plan politique de quelque façon que
ce soit on est on est plus loin je vous
dirais d'un début de dialogue
constitutionnel qu'on l'était au
lendemain du référendum souvenez-vous à
l'époque 97 je pense y avait une ce
qu'on appelait la déclaration cargo rick
hallet pas très loin mais où les
provinces étaient quand même entendus
pour dire oui le capi le québec est une
société unique et cetera mais là on veut
même plus entendre parler de ces
questions là alors 20 ans plus tard
c'est la panne générale de riz et vinça
sur le loving on ne s'entendra jamais
sur les faits réels est ce que ça plus
rebuter ou aider dépendant de quelqu'un
on aime en tout cas cest on le marque
que vous lisez dans mes pensées parce
que c'est exactement la réflexion que je
me ferai d'abord ça donne des ça donne
de ça rappelle des souvenirs et ça ne
nous rajeunit pas ça parce que nous
étions je crois bien tous les trois
tout cas moi j'ai été directement dans
la main mais je suis michèle aussi on
était tous les deux au soleil allez pas
vous battre et je crois bien de mémoire
que oui gt gt agitait la lbeq
effectivement la question moi j'ai
toujours eu l'impression début de
réponse ça vaut ce que ça vaut que ça
avait plutôt nuit
mouvement dit non parce qu'il y avait eu
une réaction épidermique de plusieurs
électeurs québécois qui avait réagi en
cédant ces pauvres est que ces six et la
saskatchewan la colombie-britannique
puis la banlieue d'ottawa qui vient d'un
autobus pour nous dire pour qui voter
mais ça avait été un moment assez assez
assez intense très très très émotif que
de voir tous ces canadiens débarquer
massivement montréal la plaque pas pour
la première fois de leur vie d'ailleurs
la main sur le coeur en pleurant
beaucoup pleuré d'ailleurs en suppliant
les québécois de rester je suis d'accord
avec michel on veut repousser bientôt
parce que je pense pour qu'on vous
revoir référendum bientôt mais je pense
pas non plus qu'on va se lancer dans des
négociations constitutionnelles en est
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
cette dernière semaine
puis un documentaire que l'on repasse et
redit à 21h hier et ce soir c'est la
dernière semaine cette dernière semaine
politique
je sais pas si on va revivre ce sont en
tout cas c'était d'une intensité
inégalée à couvrir ça je me souviens
chaque jour vous en souvenez également
mesdames et messieurs la maison aussi
messieurs merci beaucoup à voir si les
salua la prochaine à voir